Science is a slow process and it’s yet to
answer many of the great questions about life,
death, time, space etc.
But some people are rather impatient and would
rather make up their own mystical answers
to life's great mysteries.
People often turn to theology, philosophy
and the occult, to try and find answers of
their own.
Mysticism is the search for apparent hidden
truths through a range of special techniques
such as meditation, rituals, spiritual development,
certain drugs, or by just wearing a second
hand kimono and quoting David Bowie lyrics.
So today we look at the dark and rather fearsome
never-world of mysticism and discover some
of the most influential mystics in history.
Aleister Crowley was an occultist, a painter,
a novelist, a mountaineer, a poet, and possibly
a spy for Great Britain.
The press, of the late nineteen-hundreds,
were not very fond of Crowley and dubbed him
“The Wickedest Man in the World” since
they said he was a Satanist.
He founded the religion of Thelema and wrote
The Book of Law, which contains its guidelines.
He wrote it in 1904 in Cairo, during his honeymoon,
which I’m sure his wife, Rose, was delighted
about.
The main concept of Thelema is “Do what
thou wilt".
Crowley had previously been a member of the
famous occult society The Golden Dawn but
they were not fans of his bisexuality and
lifestyle so he left after about a year, losing
out on his Egyptian clothing discount card
and subscription to Spooky Tales monthly.
It’s thought that his membership could have
been an intelligence operation to undermine
Samuel Liddell Mathers, one of Golden Dawn’s
founders.
There are many other events in Crowley’s
life that could have been undercover work,
such as when he wrote German propaganda during
WW1.
Our next mystic rose all the way from the
peasant villages of Siberia to the top of
the court of Tsar Nicholas II.
Grigori Rasputin left behind his wife and
three remaining children in his early twenties
to become a monk, claiming he’d had a vison
from Our Lady of Kazan.
By 30, he had become a religious wanderer,
walking between holy places and receiving
hospitality in exchange for religious wisdom
and likes on Instagram.
Through his unique interpretations of the
scriptures, and his hypnotic steely gaze,
he quickly built a following and ended up
in St Petersburg around 1904, where he was
eventually introduced to the Tsar.
He cemented his place with the royal family
through his mystical healing powers.
He supposedly helped the Tsar’s son, Alexei,
recover from near death through the power
of prayer but it’s probably down to the
fact that he stopped him taking aspirin, which
was having a savage effect on the boy’s
haemophilia.
He became a trusted advisor to the royals
and even helped them to take major military
decisions during WW1, encouraging them to
withdraw large numbers of troops, either to
reduce casualties or perhaps to free up German
troops to move westwards and defeat the British.
We weren't this crazy monk’s biggest fans
and it’s been rumoured British Intelligence
had a hand in his mysterious death.
It could have just been the work of the Russian
aristocracy though, since they were not fond
of Rasputin either, thanks to his influence
and his slow descent into debauchery, given
that he grew a love of dessert wines and brothels.
His body was found floating in the river and
it’s alleged that he was poisoned with cyanide,
shot in the kidney and head and then drowned.
If you’re going to murder someone, you may
as well do it right.
Another Russian now, born some forty years
before Rasputin in 1831.
Helena Blavatsky was a spirit medium who co-founded
the Theosophical Society.
Theosophy is the idea that you can find salvation
through discovering the mysteries of the universe,
presumably by being really really good at
googling.
The aim of the group was to follow The Intelligent
Evolution of All Existence, something which
our modern world has definitely fought hard
against, just take a look around.
Helena claimed to have gathered various ancient
wisdom and psychic powers from her travels
around the world starting in 1849, from the
Americas to India and Tibet.
Her biographers suspect that this was a lie
and she was actually just in Europe, photoshopping
the Himalayas into her selfies while she was
really sitting in a Starbucks somewhere in
Poland.
Hey we’ve all done it, Helena.
She did become hugely famous for her occult
teachings and although now her name is less
well known, in those times it was recognised
internationally, as much as any modern trend
setting guru.
She was basically the Kim Kardashian of the
occult, with a smaller bottom.
A more modern mystic now.
Nirmala Srivastava, who died in 2011, was
the founder of Sahaja Yoga, a practice that
covers a bit more than tight leggings and
being able to suck your own toes.
It’s all about reaching a state of awareness
and unlocking your Kundalini.
Kundalini is said to be a body energy that
flows through your various Chakras, which
are like invisible USB ports that run down
the centre of your being.
This is why you should never drop a yoga teacher
in a bath, they may electrocute themselves.
The general aim is to reach thoughtless awareness,
where you understand everything but you’re
not really paying attention, a bit like when
you keep eating peanuts even though you’re
not really hungry.
She claimed in 1979 to be the embodiment of
Shakti, the Hindu idea of cosmic energy that
runs throughout the universe.
She’s also named herself the Maitreya, from
Buddhism, and Mahdi, of Islam.
She also claimed the Iron Throne and said
she knew what was in the suitcase in Pulp
Fiction.
And finally, a woman with an astonishing life,
who helped lead the American suffrage movement
and was the first ever female to run for president.
Victoria Woodhull was born in rural Ohio to
an illiterate mother and a con-man father.
She was a bright child at school but could
not attend often and had to leave very young
when her father burnt their mill down in a
shady insurance scam.
She then became a magnetic healer, by following
the work of Austrian mystic Franz Mesmer,
and probably a good dash of her old man’s
con man skills.
But she quickly moved on to greater things.
While still supporting the spiritualist movement,
her and her sister became the first women
to open a stock broking firm when they set
up on Wall St in 1870.
Within a few successful months, they used
the money they had raised to launch a newspaper,
primarily as a tool to back Victoria’s presidential
campaign.
The paper focussed on feminist issues, supporting
ideas such as free love, vegetarianism, sex
education and legalised prostitution.
It was like Vogue, if you swapped all the
adverts for actual content.
When the 1872 presidential vote came around,
Victoria was actually in prison, since she
had ruffled some feathers by devoting a full
paper issue to the affair between Elizabeth
Tilton and Reverend Henry Ward Beecher, a
prominent Protestant minister in New York,
highlighting the hypocrisy of the sexual double
standard between men and woman, that had led
her to believe in free love.
We would all like to find the hidden secrets
of the universe and unlock some kind of secret
path to happiness and enlightenment, but if
you want to become a mystic you first need
to get a really cool sounding name.
I mean just look at the people we’ve talked
about today, Crowley, Rasputin, Blavatsky,
Srivastava.
Obviously, as it seems, one needs a sufficiently
awesome name to be able to align one’s chakras,
reach a higher level of being and heal the
sick.
I’m afraid if you’re going to call yourself
“Steve the mystic” you’re not going
to be so mystical now are you?